[Music]  good to see you a ghostwriter follows on  what one who's s looks like we've found  our number-one suspect let's do this I'm  a ghostwriter release characters from  the book unless they were here to help  us I am pretty good at solving mysteries  sparkles their memories left behind by  other people  this is incredible follow the money use  the best superpower ever give me a break  you can talk to ghosts telling me  there's a monster on the loose monster  Frankenstein it was foolish of me to  create life cool we have very different  definitions of cool we should be  formulating a plan to destroy the  monster let's see if she can help us  with her super powers watching memories  is way harder than it looks  handle the sparkles  courtesy Ruben are stuck in a sparkle  this has never happened before we have  to solve this mystery it's the only way  to get to the truth listen heat them  [Music]  we come in peace see I got this